in Western Ukraine where Russian forces
have attacked the area around the
airport of leviv the extent of the
destruction is unclear at this point but
the city's mayor says Russian missiles
hit the uh the aircraft maintenance
plant not the airport itself up until
now leviv had been largely spared from
major attacks the city is located less
than a hundred kilometers east of the
Polish border and has taken in some 200
000 internally displaced people since
the war started
we can now speak to DW correspondent
Matthias berlingo who is in leviv in
Western Ukraine Matthias we understand
several blasts have been heard in leviv
what more do you know about that
yeah as you have already said it was
these blasts were near the airport smoke
was seen coming
rising from the airport area however it
seems that the target was not the
airport itself but the maintenance and
repair facility for planes and that's in
line what with what we've seen in other
parts of Western Ukraine uh fighting on
the ground has been largely limited to
the Eastern parts of the country the
Southern and the northern limited is a
bad word because these are vast areas
but the West has so far not been
threatened with Invasion but there have
been airstrikes throughout the whole
country and they have been mostly
targeting uh facilities that for example
can be used by the Air Force the
Ukrainian Air Force and uh so that's
airports and and also military and
military bases and all kinds of
strategic targets and this maintenance
facility where planes are repaired is
one of is in line with that
is there any reason to doubt that it was
in fact a Russian attack
who else would damage a Ukrainian
plane repair facility if it's not Russia
Ukraine would be shooting in its own
foot besides that there is no evidence
at all that Ukraine has been firing
rockets on its own territory and there
are no other parties to this I mean it
could be a Belarusian missile but or it
could be a Russian missile which is the
most likely a scenario fired from
Belarusian territory but there are two
parties to this conflict and it's
obviously that this was fired from the
other party Matthias how safe is it in
live now
it's hard to say I mean as we have uh
this is one example but they have also
been uh other examples of rockets fired
on cities like Leaf there has been an
attack on on a military training center
a few days ago that is near Leaf so
there are frequent air raid alarms but
we have not seen any of the
indiscriminate bombing of Civilian
facilities infrastructure residential
quarters that we have seen in those
russian-speaking parts of Ukraine like
kharkif or in the capital of Kiev or
Mario Paul
um so uh it's uh relatively safe and
that is why all these refugees are here
they're here of course on their way out
of the country because this is near the
border with the EU but they're also here
because this part of the country is
still considered relatively safe however
it's a war and things can come down from
the sky anywhere in Ukraine
um I'm curious what does that tell you
about the Russian strategy in targeting
Levi from Matthias
it's as
it really a change from what we've seen
before Russia has targeted anything that
they would seem that they would consider
a military Target and this has been
mostly infrastructure that could be used
by uh by by by the Air Force the
Ukrainian Air Force which is still which
is small and which is definitely not in
control of the Skies but which is still
active and which is still inflicting
damage on uh the Russian Air Force and
on Russian positions
um so it's kind of an expected Target
other airports visit airport for example
that's another town in Western Ukraine
that has largely been spared of attacks
but the airport has also been targeted
and uh the airport of lutzk which is
another town here so it's pretty much in
line with that I don't think Russia is
in the position or is willing to extend
its Warfare it's on the ground Warfare
or its
shelling of Civilian infrastructure at
this moment to Western Ukraine I think
Russia has pretty much reached its
limits for now but of course they are
trying to Target these these military
potentially military-used facilities
Matthias Berlinger in Libya many thanks
Matthias
the besieged port city of mariopol has
experienced some of Russia's fiercest
bombardments local officials say about
80 percent of the city's dwellings have
been destroyed and over 350 000 people
are trapped without heat and other basic
necessities on Wednesday Russian forces
bombed a theater Sheltering hundreds of
civilians 130 people have been rescued
according to mariopol's Mayor the full
extent of casualties is unclear
DW's Nick Connelly managed to get
through to a 19 year old named Yuri in
mariopal who sent us these voice
messages
right now I hear planes
I hear shooting every five or ten
minutes
the sound of fighting never goes away
[Music]
it's been days since intense shelling
started here where I am now
Ukrainian and Russian forces are
fighting and I haven't been able to
leave my house
this is the fifth day I've been stuck
inside
[Music]
I've seen people dead on the streets
with my own eyes
near my house there's a shop I was
nearby when it was hit by a shell I went
to see what happened and saw four bodies
they were probably hit by shrapnel their
bodies were only picked up two days
later
three or four days after War began
people started running out of food
the shops were shut and people started
raiding shops that had been damaged by
shelling in search of food
another three or four days later people
were so hungry that they started
breaking into shops that had stayed
undamaged because they needed to eat
our city is gone it doesn't exist
anymore it's been destroyed the shops
have been smashed up by hungry people
and our buildings have been pulverized
my friends went round the city and saw
five-story buildings where only the
cellar was left
you get used to all the explosions
you're not really scared anymore when
something hits nearby I've stopped
running into the cellar it just becomes
normal
I get stressed when there's no internet
and I can't reach my relatives or my
girlfriend who already managed to get to
Germany
all I think about is when I'll be able
to get out of here and see her
the explosions and the shooting aren't
as scary anymore as losing touch with
the people you love me
[Music]
well since we spoke to him Yuri has
managed to escape mariopal many others
have been less fortunate with attempts
to organize reliable evacuation
corridors failing as Ukraine accuses
Russia of ignoring its ceasefire
commitments
we're joined Now by yaphinia kraftcho
she's a Ukrainian MP and a member of
President zielinski's servant of the
people party uh welcome to DW we really
appreciate you joining us you and your
country have now endured more than three
weeks of War let me Begin by asking you
how you're doing personally
well um I'm doing as every MP is doing
I'm doing my job
um I'm working SMP because the
parliament has been gathering for a few
times uh since this full-scale war
started also I'm part of uh we'll call
this woman uh diplomatic Battalion and
I've just returned from Strasbourg where
we had meetings in Euro European
Parliament and Council of Europe and
actually Council of Europe uh expelled
Russia from uh from membership and it's
the first international organization
that had a courage to exclude
Russia in from from the membership my
husband is fighting and my daughter is
sleeping in the basement and then
learning in online school next day so
it's the same thing as all other people
experiencing of course those who are in
her given Marie up the experience and a
lot more because they don't have
food water electricity but they do still
have hope
that we will get a proper support to end
this war of aggression and terrorism
because it's simply terrorism what Putin
does you mentioned the fact that your
husband is fighting do you talk to him
on a daily basis
yes we do
a daily basis and he's doing fine so um
yes he's okay he's alive let me ask you
this the the mayor of leviv today said
that Russia attacked the city's airport
area the Viva is in the west of Ukraine
and many ukrainians have fled there from
other parts of the country do you expect
Russia to Target the West more
uh we expect that uh Russia could Target
more if they do not
um you know have any
um like going on the ground because as
you see uh they've stopped in uh going
into the cave they don't have
um ammunition they'll have people enough
to uh to see skills so right now they
are targeting civilians more and more uh
the the trying to get airport and leave
it's something that we we've seen from
the very first day of this war but also
uh an hour ago a neighborhood civilian
neighborhoods in here was targeted there
was no war facilities over there it just
uh you know just people living in um in
high storage houses so what Russians do
not probably have the uh proper number
of missiles to cover the whole
residential areas of Ukraine but they
would do it just to scare people
yeah and they certainly have many troops
to do that I I wonder
um as you continue to endure this war
whether you feel that your country is
getting enough help from European
countries
well of course uh thankful for the help
already God but of course it's not
um enough to uh to have proper defense
in Disguise because why we're talking
about this uh um green courted us about
the people currently because they uh
shell the cities the normal peaceful
sieges from the skies we can get even
counter attacks on the ground but when
they're hitting with missiles by the way
this missiles that hit can leave uh
region they were shot from Black Sea so
it's the missiles that can hit a long
way and it was confirmed by um by by our
army it was six missiles cruise missiles
two of them were taken off by our air
defense system but four uh hit the
whatever area the mayor will will tell
more about the consequences
um so uh why we need uh air Jazz to
fight Russians in the and why we need
this air defense system to take off
these missiles because they are
targeting
um
Targets in all Ukraine and killing
people every day and by the way I would
like I'm sorry I would like to comment
yesterday's tweet of your counselor
about that it's only war of Putin you
know I would like to bring you some
numbers from the sociology uh that radio
free Liberty had taken in Russia in
recent days so uh and it says that three
out of four three fourths of so almost
75 percent of Russians they support war
in Ukraine and when they asked about
this war they say they feel proud and
they feel happy and today in Russia they
will celebrate celebrate uh an eighth
year of anniversary of annexation of
Crimea they have concerts all over the
country and Putin will be addressed in
the nation
um of course they're getting mostly the
news from propaganda channels but that's
the reality they do support this war and
I have another sociologist saying that
uh 75 percent of Russians say that the
next country could be Poland should be
Poland and other European countries
should be targeted and it's okay and if
you do not see Germany in this list it
is it mean that you know they will not
move forward and forward uh to uh
Eastern European countries such as
Poland such as Lithuania such as Czech
Republic Bulgaria and so on you've made
your point resoundingly clear and we do
appreciate that yavenia uh Craft Truck a
member of Ukraine's servant of the
people party thank you so much for
joining us
the war in Ukraine has left many feeling
helpless wondering what to do in the
face of Russia's aggression actor and
former governor of California Arnold
Schwarzenegger seems to be no exception
in a heartfelt video he posted on social
media he addressed the Russian people
telling them their government was lying
to them about events in Ukraine
I'm speaking to you today because there
are things that are going on in the
world that are being kept from you
terrible things that you should know
about you see Ukraine did not start this
war
neither did nationalists or Nazis
those in power in the Kremlin started
this war
this is not the Russian people's War
no every bambo every shell that falls is
falling not on an enemy
but on the school
or Hospital
or home
I know that the Russian people are not
aware of such things are happening
so I urge the Russian people and the
Russian soldiers in Ukraine to
understand the propaganda and the
disinformation that you're being told
I ask you to help me spread the truth
and to President Putin I say
you started this war you are leading
this war you can stop this war
Let's cross over now to our Russia
analyst Roman gunterenko in Bonn uh
Roman extremely strong words there from
Arnold Schwarzenegger how effective is
this message and will it reach the
Russian public
well um I would say it's probably the
best message that I've seen from the
West
um to the Russian people uh because
um persons like celebrities like Arnold
Schwarzenegger used to be very popular
in Russia especially with my generation
are the people who grew up in the 80s
and
um it's um it's difficult to estimate
how this will resonate because Russians
have a very limited access to social
networks Western social networks like
Twitter or Facebook but they do have
YouTube they have telegram where
Schwarzenegger also published his
message so what I've seen so far there's
been a positive reaction on YouTube for
example positive comments but there are
also a lot of Russian polls uh doing
typical what about autism saying uh hey
um Schwarzenegger what about Syria what
about Iraq other countries where U.S
invaded why were you silent at that time
so um um I would say that some Russian
critical media also published that and
this is probably the best way to reach
Russians but you have to understand that
more than half of Russian population
supports this war so the effect would be
limited
Roman Western officials are accusing
Russia of not taking the peace talks
seriously yet the Kremlin says Russia is
putting colossal effort into talks on a
possible peace deal with Ukraine what do
you make of this
well from Russian point of view you
don't have to reconcile that because
President Putin has made it very clear
he's not going to stop the war will
continue until Ukraine surrenders this
is what he said and this is what he's
repeating in nearly every day
um so
um as as to the peace talks um I'm very
very skeptical I think it's it's an
attempt a Russian attempt
to disguise the West to disguise Ukraine
maybe to win some time to pull up
resources because the Russian offensive
is not going well and I wouldn't be very
optimistic about those negotiations so
uh for the coming days and week I think
the situation will get worse
President Biden called Vladimir Putin a
murderous dictator a pure Thug who is
waging in a moral war against the people
of Ukraine how bothered is the Kremlin
by this name calling from the White
House you think
well we've had some criticism from the
Kremlin but I think they actually do not
care we are beyond the point where they
care about Western remarks or what what
western leaders say about Russia or
Vladimir Putin and I think um also such
remarks like um by President Obama in 20
2014 when he said Russia was a regional
power and there are experts in the west
who tend to say that was a mistake I'm I
don't actually think that that President
Putin cares about such things he sees
himself as a big commander who is doing
historic uh who is waging historic Wars
or bringing uh Glory back to Russia so
he doesn't really care I think
Russia analysts a Roman gunterenko many
many thanks Roman
the World Health Organization says
indiscriminate attacks across Ukraine
have damaged hospitals and crippled
Health Care Services who director
General Ted Rose giveresos warned the
war could have a devastating impact on
Ukraine citizens and Health Care system
for decades
the disruption to services and supplies
in Ukraine is posing an extreme risk to
people with cardiovascular diseases
cancer diabetes HIV and TB
which are among the leading codes of
mortality in Ukraine
here's a look now at some of the other
developments in the conflict the United
Nations under Secretary General has
called for an investigation into the
civilian casualties in Ukraine speaking
at the U.N security Council Rosemary
DeCarlo said international law prohibits
attacks on civilians and those
responsible must be held accountable
Russian strikes have destroyed schools
hospitals and residential buildings
Australia and Japan have announced new
sanctions on Russia as punishment for
the invasion of Ukraine the sanctions
Target multiple individuals and
organizations including Russia's central
bank finance ministry and two oligarchs
linked to Australia's mining industry
NATO Secretary General Yen stoltenberg
says the alliance must prevent any
escalation of the war Beyond Ukraine's
borders he was speaking in Berlin after
meeting German foreign minister angelena
burbach the foreign minister said more
German troops would be sent to NATO's
Eastern borders
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
says Russia is making no meaningful
diplomatic effort to end the war in
Ukraine he also said he agrees with
President Biden that Russia has
committed war crimes Biden added that he
believes Russia's Putin is a murderous
dictator waging on a moral War
a war against the people meanwhile NATO
has been conducting a massive military
drill in Norway the alliance says the
Maneuvers are designed to test troops
Readiness for combat in cold conditions
some thirty thousand soldiers from 27
countries are involved DW's Jack pyrek
reports from Camp Rena in Norway
fire
and maneuver
2 500 French polish Spanish and
Portuguese soldiers taking part in this
NATO exercise called Brilliance jump the
soldiers told us the invasion of Ukraine
has bolstered their determination to
defend their countries
this exercise we we actually can see
that we are a solid group it's we were
we are working like a one organism and
if we are together we will find a way
these drills have been in planning for
two years they're using the cold
conditions in Norway to train artillery
infantry and Specialists who can deal
with chemical and biological attacks
checking interoperability between
countries
these are the sounds and the sights of
War but this isn't War this is training
drills practice right now the NATO
military Alliance has no plans to send
troops like these into the very real
theater of war in Ukraine
these troops are on a five-day notice to
deploy but currently only within NATO's
borders attending the drills General
Vollmer was the second highest officer
in the German Army and now a top NATO
Commander told DW news exclusively he's
greatly in favor of the recent move by
the German government to increase annual
military spending to two percent of GDP
with an additional one-off injection of
100 billion euros our neighboring
countries are counting on Germany and
with this announcement and with the will
now to to rebuild forces reinforce them
again that is a strong statement and of
course from the military perspective and
as a NATO Commander I'm counting on
Germany that they will rebuild
capabilities they gave away many years
ago the exercises here at Camp Renner
are also aimed at reassuring people
living in Norway in the nearby town of
hammer people told us they're fully
aware of the drills and Norway has the
border with with Russia and if
we never know what can happen so
I think it's also a lot of fear in
Norway
what can happen we don't know NATO will
protect us
and I think Ukraine
would have it better if they were innate
or no I'm afraid of that because I think
we have to work People to People in
peace process and and not the military
many of the soldiers present here will
now participate in a 35
000 troop strong drill cold response
conducted by Norway's own Armed Forces
with NATO involvement the commanders say
these exercises aren't designed as
warnings for Russia only to prepare
defensively